Z I was wondering what British stuff um
Tom has taught you about and he's
slanging I do this thing when I'm around
him for a while where I speak with
British inflections but not the British
accent you have like an English Cadence
with while saying it as an American yeah
we go down so we're like like where
where are you going and you goes where
you going yeah your favorite one is I
say yeah he was funny would he yeah
funny Wy and she says that all the time
he's funny wasn't he yeah he was funny
wasn't he something that is that you
always say that at the end yeah that was
funny that that was funny it was funny
wasn't it was he that that